every day an incredible amount of life  passes over our heads we can see things  like birds and bats but there's an even  larger number of bugs researchers in  England used an upward pointing radar  beam to quantify just how many smaller  insects were also collected in nets hung  from a blimp using radar they could  track the size of the insects as well as  their speed and direction this study  tracked many kinds of insects over a  10-year period to find fraud patterns  surprisingly many insects migrated north  and south with the seasons just like  birds seasonal migration was thought to  be rare among insects but it actually  seems that many large insects do it  meaning they must have a very good sense  of direction insects flying at great  heights outweigh migrating birds in the  same region by a factor of eight the  researchers estimate more than three  trillion bucks fly over southern England  each year that's about 3200 tons or  twenty thousand reindeer  [Music]